[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sie was
und ich wünsche ihnen allen einen guten
abend gemeinsam mit katja stresow hier
die nachher den sport hat wie immer sehr
gern schwimmen gelernt und das sind
unsere wichtigsten themen an diesem
samstag
deutschland vor dem wahltag bis zur
letzten minute kämpfen die parteien um
die die noch unentschlossen sind
morgen entscheidet sich auch das rennen
ums rote rathaus in berlin und wer
künftig in mecklenburg vorpommern
regiert
und explosive lage auf la palma kommt
der vulkan cumbia nicht zur ruhe
wir beginnen mit einem wahlsonntag der
seine schatten vorauswirft eigentlich
war bei den allermeisten parteien
gestern offiziell schluss mit wahlkampf
aber natürlich geht es auch heute noch
um jede einzelne stimme vor allem dann
wenn das rennen wie aktuell so offen ist
und natürlich sind auch die spitzenleute
heute noch mal unterwegs der samstag vor
der wahl karl hinterleitner fast ihnen
zusammen ein
letzter schoder die drei kandidierenden
fürs kanzleramt sind auf der zielgeraden
sein wahlkampf hätte kaum besser laufen
können deutliche gewinne in diesem jahr
im sommer die union überholt in den
mittelpunkt seiner rede heute stellt
olaf scholz soziale frage ich habe mich
immer dafür eingesetzt dass deutschland
einen mindestlohn bekommt weil ich
einfach zu viele kennen und
kennengelernt habe insofern nicht
verdient und ich möchte das jetzt noch
mal einen großen schritt machen und
dafür sorgen dass der mindestlohn gehen
wir heute in deutschland haben nach oben
gesetzt wird dass er auf zwölf euro
angehoben nur einen steinwurf entfernt
scholz direkte wahlkreis konkurrentin
annalena baerbock bundesweit führte sie
die umfrage einmal an jetzt wird sie
wohl als dritter durchs ziel gehen
berbalk noch einmal mit den grünen
kernthemen
wir haben in der pandemie aber auch in
dem wahlkampf überall gespielt dass
menschen sagen wir können das doch mit
dem klimaschutz vor ort wir können
bessere kitas und schulen schaffen im
gesundheitsbereich sind pflegerinnen und
pfleger über sich hinausgewachsen und
dieser wunsch nach einer erneuerung
darum geht es jetzt am sonntag das zu
wählen und mit voller kraft in die neue
bundesregierung einzuengen die größte
bühne heute für armin laschet auftritt
mit der kanzlerin in varel der
unionskandidat liegt zurück aber es ist
knapp laschet waren vor allem
linksbündnis
können
also
das waren
23 leute die das glauben der rest der
deutschen glaubt das nicht es war der
wohl endgültigen schlusspunkt eines
wechselvoll im wahlkampf noch rund 24
stunden bis zur ersten hochrechnung
untergehen wir zweifeln unser zdf
wahlstudio nach berlin zu bettina
schausten genannt bettina beginnen wir
vielleicht mit dem blick aufs große
ganze eine wahl wie es sie lange nicht
gegeben hat was sind denn die punkte die
diese wahl morgen entscheiden
also ein paar dinge scheinen bei
auswertungen der umfragen ja schon
ziemlich klar nämlich dass die union
kräftig verlieren dürfte die spd und die
grünen gewinnen werden aber der
entscheidende punkt ist natürlich wer
liegt vorn dass die union mit armin
laschet doch noch auf rang eins kommt
das schließen die demoskopen nicht aus
und es wird für laschet auch
entscheidend sein wenn er eine
regierungsbildung trotz erwartbarer
verluste beanspruchen will es ist ein
enges rennen das ist vielleicht die
wichtigste prognose für morgen es wird
ein hochinteressanter wahlabend das kann
man jetzt schon sagen eine wahlnacht
möglicherweise auf was genau müssen wir
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer und ihr in
berlin dann einstellen
also es sicher nicht verkehrt ein
bisschen geduld mitzubringen
interessant ist das thema corona spielt
inhaltlich für die leute keine
dominierende rolle aber es hat dann eben
doch auswirkungen weil viele sich für
die briefwahl entschieden haben beim
letzten mal man dass 29 prozent jetzt
werden rund 45 prozent rivella erwartet
und das macht das geschäft natürlich für
die demoskopen wirklich schwieriger wenn
es dann knappe dann dürfte es auch lange
dauern bis zum ergebnis wir werden sie
hier im zdf wahlstudio beobachten wo
auch alle zahlen und daten von den
beiden anderen wahlen in
mecklenburg-vorpommern und in berlin ein
laufen das ganze ab 17 uhr 18 uhr
pünktlich die prognose der
forschungsgruppe wahlen und dann sind
wir weiter dann sehen wir weiter vielen
dank bettina und bis morgen und alle
informationen zur bundestagswahl also
zum beispiel wie gewählt wird und welche
wahlkreise besonders auf der kippe
stehen finden sie bei uns in der zdf-
heute und morgen natürlich alle zahlen
und analysen und hintergründe ebenfalls
dort ganz grad schon kurz gehört nicht
nur ein neuer bundestag wird morgen
gewählt auch zwei bundesländer stimmen
über ihre parlamente ab guck mal zuerst
nach berlin wo es morgen sehr spannend
wird denn mit spd grünen und cdu liegen
gleich drei parteien in umfragen rund um
20 und an der spitze gibt es auf jeden
fall einen wechsel der regierende
bürgermeister michael müller von der spd
tritt nicht mehr an markus gross über
den schluss des wahlkampfs in der
hauptstadt
rote rosen zum wahlkampfabschluss
franziska giffey zuversichtlich heute
morgen
die spitzenkandidatin hat ihre spd mit
einem kurs der mitte aus dem umfragetief
geholt liegt nun nach den aktuellen zdf
zahlen mit 22 prozent vorn ich möchte
gerne dass berlin in den nächsten zehn
jahren zu den bedeutendsten
wirtschaft technologie und auch kreativ
und kulturstandort europas wird das ist
unser auftrag und lebenswert und
bezahlbar bleibt bettina jarasch
verteilt türkische leckereien
wahlkampf-endspurt die berliner grünen
lange in den umfragen führende sind
jetzt knapp hinter die spd zurück
gefallen rot-rot-grün will jahres
fortsetzen allerdings unter grüner
führung ich möchte regierende
bürgermeisterin werden weil wir die
stadt umbauen müssen wir müssen sie
rüsten für den klima wandelt wir müssen
unser versprechen einlösen und die
verkehrswende endlich auch an den
stadtrand bringen kai wegner von der cdu
will rot- rot-grün ablösen starke
wirtschaft eine sichere stadt darum geht
es ihm in den umfragen die cdu derzeit
auf platz drei wegner hofft auf ein
bündnis bitte spd leute wollen einen
politischen wechsel sie wollen einen
politischen neustart und dafür steht die
cdu und dafür treten wir an aber dass
ich mich ganz optimistisch dass das
wahlergebnis deutlich besser wird als
unsere umfragen die linke mit klaus
lederer an der spitze setzt voll auf die
enteignungs initiative großer
wohnungskonzern mieten und wohnen das
top thema des wahlkampfs noch die linke
schwächelt in den umfragen der noch
zuversicht ich glaube dass die
berlinerinnen und berliner wissen dass
eine linke eine starke linke eine
garantie dafür ist dass hier soziale
politik und eine vernünftige
mietenpolitik weitergemacht wird und was
glaube ich vielen leuten auch wichtig
sein der wahlkampf der afg und ihrer
spitzenkandidatin brinker verläuft nur
schleppend in den umfragen unter zehn
prozent die rechtsaußenpartei hofft auf
eine letzte mobilisierungskampagne
da gibt es noch viele unentschlossene
die wir noch in den letzten tagen
gewinnen können und ansonsten ist berlin
halte eine links grüne stadt das müssen
wir einfach zur kenntnis nehmen die fdp
führt sebastian czaja an ein
zweistelliges ergebnis und eine
regierungsbeteiligung sein wahlziel
jetzt geht es erstmal darum auf den
letzten metern noch zu werden dafür dass
ein regierungswechsel in berlin möglich
ist und damit tatsächlich auch jenseits
von rot rot grüne bündnisse entstehen
können wer regiert künftig die
hauptstadt ein spannendes finale um den
einzug ins rote rathaus
und dann weiter nach mecklenburg
vorpommern dort scheint die sache klarer
zu sein die spd von amtsinhaberin
manuela schwesig hat einen deutlichen
vorsprung interessant wird's auf den
weiteren plätzen aus schwerin jetzt
susanne seite sie steht im mittelpunkt
des spd wahlkampfes ministerpräsidentin
manuela schwesig wirbt für sich als
corona krisenmanagerin mit
bundespolitische erfahrung die umfragen
sehen die spd bei 39 prozent weit vor
jeder konkurrenz natürlich gibt es auch
noch viele unentschlossen und wir wollen
vor allem den bürgerinnen und bürgern in
mv sagen das ist wichtig ist dass alle
zur wahl gehen und dass wir sehr um
unterstützung für die spd bitten damit
ich meine arbeit fortsetzen kann haustür
wahlkampf in greifswald cdu
spitzenkandidat michael sack will die
themen wie eine starke wirtschaft noch
mal persönlich anbringen vom ziel die
groko künftig anzuführen hat er sich
verabschiedet umfragen sehen die cdu bei
historisch niedrigen 14
ganz klar sagen das ziel werden wir wohl
nicht erreichen das ist nicht aufgeben
aber ganz klar wir wollen regieren wir
wollen mitgestalten mv aber normal damit
wie die afg mit spitzenkandidat nikolaus
kramer punkten und kritisiert damit die
korona maßnahmen 2016 zog sie als
zweitstärkste kraft in den landtag
umfragen sehen sie jetzt bei 16 dann
werden wir als oppositionsführer die
regierung vertreiben werden unsere
ureigensten aufgabe als opposition
nachkommen kontrolle der regierung und
es ist ja mitnichten so dass wir keine
akzente setzen können vor allem mit dem
thema bildung tritt die
spitzenkandidatin der linken simone
oldenburg an und hofft trotz niedriger
umfragewerte von 11% auf eine koalition
mit der spd
veränderung hatten wir mal den spruch
beginnt mit opposition muss ja aber
nicht in der position verharren
selbstverständlich sind wir bereit in
mecklenburg vorpommern zu regieren die
grünen wollen nach fünf jahren wieder
ins parlament genauso wie die fdp nach
zehn jahren beide liegen in umfragen
über der fünf prozent hürde und wären
damit drin im schweriner landtag
und so viel zu den wahlen morgen mehr
jetzt in der sendung kurz die pandemie
lage in deutschland die korona zahlen
sinken weiter das robert koch institut
meldet 7211 neue infektionen in 24
stunden das sind 1
1690 weniger als vor einer woche 62
todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben tage
inzidenz liegt aktuell bei
60,6
unser nächstes thema entspannung in
einem jahrelangen konflikt die
finanzchefin des chinesischen
technologiekonzerns huawei darf kanada
verlassen
london june war dort 2018 auf drängen
der usa festgesetzt worden ein vorwurf
der us regierung banken betrug dank
eines deals mit den us-behörden ist die
chinesin jetzt frei im gegenzug ließ
kaniskina zwei kanadische geschäftsleute
nach hause fliegen die fast genau so
lange festgehalten worden waren johannes
hano mit den details es war eine leise
ankunft heute nacht im kanadischen
calgary nach knapp drei jahren
einzelhaft in china waren die beiden
michaels wie sie in kanada genannt
werden zurück in der freiheit begrüßt
von kanadas premierminister lasten
dritter
diese beiden männer sind unvorstellbare
qualen gegangen
1000 tage lang haben die stärke
durchhaltevermögen und widerstandskraft
gezeigt
sie haben uns alles inspiriert
michael comick ex diplomat und
menschenrechtsaktivist und der
geschäftsmann michael bay wurden opfer
im großen spiel der mächte im dezember
2018 wurden sie in china verhaftet kurz
nachdem die finanzchefin des
chinesischen technologieriesen ranger
auf bitten der usa in kanada
festgenommen wurde die us-behörden
hatten sie wegen bank betrug und verstoß
gegen das iran embargo angeklagt und
lockerem hausarrest in ihrer 4 millionen
dollar villa in vancouver kämpfte sie
gegen die auslieferung und bestritt die
vorwürfe kurz nachdem die us behörden
das verfahren gestern gegen sie unter
auflagen aus setzten saß man nun flieger
nach shenzen und die beiden michaels
wurden aus ihrer einzelhaft in china
entlassen auch wenn chinas kommunisten
jeden zusammenhang bestreiten eines
macht der fall klar alle die in jeder
geschäfte machen oder sich dort
engagieren müssen ab jetzt damit rechnen
zur verhandlungsmasse zu werden chinas
kaiser diplomatie wie viele beobachter
ist nennen habe sich ausgezahlt für
china in roten kostümen rotem teppich
gefeiert wie eine film-diva stegmann jo
nach ihrer landung aus dem flugzeug eine
inszenierung die kein zweifel lässt wer
sich hier als sieger sieht
[Applaus]
halb leere supermarktregale und
tankstellen die keinen sprit mehr haben
in großbritannien werden die
lieferengpässe immer massiver die
regierung will deshalb jetzt offenbar
die strengen brh exit visa regeln für
lkw-fahrer lockern das wäre eine
kehrtwende
auch heute bei den briten lange
schlangen vor den zapfsäulen an vielen
tankstellen dürfen die menschen nur noch
für 30 pfund tanken diesel und benzin
können nur noch schlecht verteilt werden
weil im land etwa 100.000 lkw fahrer
fehlen hauptgründe dafür sind der brh
exit und die korona krise
seit knapp einer woche müssen die
menschen auf la palma mit einem
vulkanausbruch leben und der cumbria auf
der kleinsten kanaren insel kommt nicht
zur ruhe mehr als 6000 einwohner mussten
ihre häuser räumen jetzt ist auch der
verkehr am flughafen der hauptstadt
santa cruz wegen der aschewolken
eingestellt unaufhaltsam erobert die
lava hektar für hektar land und bahnt
sich den weg richtung küste thomas
weiler am flughafen von la palma landet
am mittag nur die asche der flugbetrieb
ist weitgehend eingestellt und darum
sitzen viele touristen im wörtlichen
sinne auf gepackten koffern am hafen von
la palma versuchen sie von der insel zu
kommen vielen bleibt nur dieses
verkehrsmittel sind wir feinde tatsachen
gestellt worden dass leider der flug
ausfällt jetzt versuchen wir mit dem
schiff nach dem river zu fahren und
haben dann auf unsere eigenen kosten ein
flug gebucht von teneriffa nach
das geld hätte das wohl
zuvor hatten die behörden die
evakuierung weiterer auto angeordnet
denn der combo wie ich ja hatte sich
nach einer woche der eruptionen nicht
beruhigt immer wieder überrascht er die
experten
eine neue eruption hat sich gerade
ereignet und wir müssen schnell hier weg
weil sich gerade ein neuer riss an der
flanke des kegels geöffnet hat
experten sagen die akute phase des
vulkans sei hochexplosiv dabei sind auch
anwohner die bislang nicht gezwungen
waren zu gehen bereits erschöpft die
fixe tasche weg um sich abzulenken weil
du nicht den ganzen tag damit verbringen
kannst dieses monster anzusehen wie es
deine leute und deine insel auffrisst
ich fühle hilflosigkeit weil wir es so
aus der nähe siehst aber dann in
bekannten nicht helfen kannst sie sind
wie familie
die explosionen der ascheregen und der
lärm zermürben die anwohner weiter und
ein ende ist bislang nicht absehbar
unglaubliche bilder jetzt aber den sport
in der sendung und das bist du katja ich
glaube schon es geht los mit fußball er
bleibt sich hat sich nach dem stolper
start in der bundesliga mit einem
überragenden sieg zurückgemeldet zum
leidwesen von hertha bsc das sind die
ergebnisse des sechsten spieltages
leipzig gewinnt gegen härter mit 6 zu 0
leverkusen mit dem vierten saisonsieg 1
0 gegen mainz wolfsburg kassiert die
erste saison-niederlage beim 1 3 in
hoffenheim frankfurt und köln spielen
unentschieden 1 1 und union gewinnt 1 0
gegen bielefeld am abend die partie
gladbach gegen dortmund ausführlich mit
allen bildern und stimmen im aktuellen
sportstudio und bereits gestern gewinn
die bayern in fürth drei zu eins in der
tabelle die bayern weiter vorn dann
leverkusen und wolfsburg dortmund kann
am abend auf rang zwei vor rutschen
hoffenheim nach dem sieg jetzt auf neun
zweite hälfte bleibt sich verbessert
sich von zwölf auf zehn dahinter die
härter und frankfurt gladbach aktuell
auf dem relegationsplatz bochum und
fürth auf den abstiegsrängen
was sagt wolfsburgs trainer mark von
bommel zur ersten saison-niederlage wir
wissen es von 23 uhr an er ist zu gast
im aktuellen sportstudio bei sven voss
zur formel 1 das qualifying zum grossen
preis von russland hatte einige
überraschungen heute parat nicht lewis
hamilton auch nicht max verstappen
holten die schnellsten zeiten auf der
regennassen strecke von sochi
rheinländer norris im mclaren war heute
tagesbester
auf abtrocknender strecke gelingt lando
norris die erste pole position seiner
karriere für mclaren die erste seit
knapp neun jahren der wm-führende max
verstappen wegen motorwechsel
strafversetzt in die letzte startreihe
schont seinen red bull und fährt nur
zwei runden zur technischen probe
weltmeister lewis hamilton hat in seinem
mercedes auf feuchtem untergrund
probleme wird nur vierter sebastian
vettel verpasste im ersten martin um 52
tausendstelsekunden die top ten mit
noris carlos sainz im ferrari und
williams pilot russell eine sehr
interessante spitzen konstellation fürs
rennen
vor zwei monaten in tokio holte ricarda
funk olympia-gold im kanuslalom heute
nun das sportliche sahnehäubchen auf dem
kuchen denn funkel waren auch gold bei
der wm in bratislava
und noch jemand freute sich über eine
medaille
glücksgefühle über gold und
jubel über silber zunächst hatte die
augsburgerin elena willig auf dem 280
meter langen wildwasser kurs an der
donau eine so starke fahrt gezeigt dass
alle nachfolgenden konkurrentinnen ihre
bestzeit nicht unterbieten konnten als
letzte kam die olympiasiegerin funk aus
bad kreuznach und holte trotz einer
torstabberührung den titel mit 25 1
sekunden vorsprung die 29-jährige siegte
vor ihrer zimmer kameraden willig und
der britin lucy
war heute im flow hat sie danach gesagt
ja im wahrsten sinne des wortes im flow
sowie wir katja jetzt ist der flow bald
vorbei denn wir haben nur noch das
wetter in der sendung das wird unruhig
morgen gibt es neue gewitter berichtet
gleichstand ich empfehle ihnen natürlich
das heute journal mit dem kollegen claus
kleber um 22 uhr 45 und dann sagen wir
alle hier vom team 19 danke für heute
rund bis morgen aber erst in allen einen
angenehmen haben
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ein neues tief nähert sich und
das bringt schauer und gewitter und
diese gewitter können durchaus im
unwetter bereich liegen also 20 bis 40
liter auf den quadratmeter bringen sie
treten punktuell auf also vereinzelt
sind diese unwetterartigen entwicklungen
möglich oder auf der vorderseite des
tiefs kommt nochmal richtig warme luft
in den osten deutschlands mit bis zu 26
grad in der nacht gibt es schon im süd
westen erste schauer und gewitter
ansonsten ist es trocken teils neblig
bei tiefsten temperaturen von 7 bis 10
grad im südosten 14 bis 15 zum beispiel
im südwesten deutschlands ja morgen am
vormittag weitere schauer und gewitter
ganz im südwesten sonst ist es trocken
teils noch neblig später scheint im
osten vor allem die sonne aber schauer
und gewitter ziehen weiter in die mitte
und wie gesagt vereinzelt mit unwetter
und das bei höchsten temperaturen von
bis zu 26 grad im osten deutschlands und
zb 19 grad richtung eifel und die
kommenden tage am montag weitere schauer
und gewitter die zehn hauptsächlich dann
weiter in den osten weil bis zu 24 grad
und auch dienstag gibt es weitere
schauer bei werten bis 21 grad ein
schöner abend